do you see now how the first check on
the government
is that we must consent but the second
check is that we do not run the
government
[Music]
in america in the government of the
united states and the federal government
what is it that the people do absolutely
none of make the laws
creating the judiciary branch
enforcing enforcement laws
they are not judges they are not
legislators
and they are not executives over the law
they are entirely excluded from the
operation of the government
isn't that odd right in england
and great britain at the time of the
american revolution
who was the executive the king
and his ministers right and who was
sovereign the king
right so the one possessing legitimate
title to rule
occupied the executive branch in athens
who was the legislature
the people the people and who was the
sovereign
the people the people athens just the
people would meet and they were always
changing their mind
and so in america
it is different because
unlike athens unlike england all the
sovereignty
is ours
we may not be governed except by our
consent
and we don't give it no governing all
government is illegitimate except with
that
and of course it follows from that that
in the practical operation of the
government since unanimity is impossible
majority rule and of course in a college
in a proper college if you disagree
somebody's wrong we're here to find out
who's wrong and who's right
well we always disagree how are we ever
going to figure it out right
but yeah so there's going to be voting
and there's going to be disagreement and
we're not going to reach unanimity
why is the majority the right thing
seems like it's more probable that more
people
since it's not a mob at that time
because they're voting on something in a
republican fashion
that they would have considered it in a
way that would refine their opinions
ooh that's really novel
i don't think it's true all men are
created equal
you got 300 people 160 want to do
a and 141 and do not a
if you do what the 140 says you've got
yourself an aristocracy
right in other words the majority of
equal souls
has to stand in for the unanimous
consent
right and in anything not fundamental or
anything that involves the ongoing
operation of the government that's what
you need
see so the point is you're going to have
majorities rule
you're going to have representation and
that gives rise to something new
and madison says that it's never
happened before it's unique
the sovereign is the people as expressed
by what i'll
introduce a new phrase that abraham
lincoln liked
the people as they expressed their will
through their constitutional majority
is the only true sovereign of a free
people
and so that's where sovereignty is
that's where the right to say
the legitimate title to rule is
but those people the sovereign are
entirely
excluded from the operation of the
government
do you see now how the first check on
the government is that we must consent
but the second check on the government
is that we
who have the power to consent do not
run the government and that second check
is a check on us
the federalist answer is that every
human
exercise of power must be restrained by
reason
and there are constitutional forms that
have to be implemented
that can help bring that out and if the
first constitutional form
is representation the method by which we
give our ongoing consent
the second is the separation
between sovereignty and power
so um you get
consent and that gives rise to
representation
and that gives rise to a separation
between the sovereign and the government
and madison says this has never been
done before
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and invite
you to explore
all of hillsdale college's online
courses they are free
and for everyone who loves to learn